[Music]
[Music]
hey folks my name is derek fisher and i
want to walk through a little bit of
threat modeling we're going to use uh
owasp's threat dragon to do a threat
model there's other tools out there that
exist one of the other more popular ones
is the microsoft threat model tool
but uh obasp threat dragon's pretty
pretty good one too it's a little more
intuitive and gives you a little more
freedom but either one's fine but in
this case we're going to use
threat dragon when we create a threat
model the first thing we're trying to
understand is what does the system look
like what are the different components
that are part of that system the
different interactions the different
boundaries
and the whole goal there is to identify
threats that exist within that system so
if you have a basic web application
with a database and external access
across the internet
then there's a lot of different threats
that are posed to that system so
creating a threat model will allow you
to identify what those threats are and
then put together a
mitigation or remediation strategy to
try to address those threats
the last part of that too is to validate
that the mitigation remediation uh are
effective and that the threats are
actually real so in some cases you might
identify threats that just don't apply
so the first thing you want to do is
create a diagram and you want to start
out with a large white board if you're
doing this in a group setting and what
you want to do is draw out the
architecture now if you're doing this by
yourself you can just go right into the
tool and build out the diagram within
the tool you can do it in powerpoint you
could do it in vizio you could do it in
any kind of drawing application as well
if you don't have a whiteboard
the diagram should be as in-depth as
possible but you don't want to create an
eye chart you don't want to make
something that's
so
large that you know it's unwieldy and
you're not able to actually get anywhere
with it you know one of the rules of
thumb that i try to use is that if i
don't have
or if the organization doesn't have
control over how to mitigate a threat
with that given part of the system then
it doesn't necessarily need to be in
scope maybe the interaction has to be
there so for instance maybe you uh work
with a a third party that is calling
your api you can't control the code on
that third party uh therefore any
threats that exist at that third in that
third party for instance maybe that
third party uh has an exposure to
cross-site scripting or something like
that well you can't fix that so it
isn't in scope now
the interaction of that third party
calling your api is absolutely in scope
so hopefully that makes a little bit of
sense so some of the things you want to
consider obviously a scope you want to
make sure that you have
all the pieces that are part of the of
the system identified in the model you
want to identify the different actors
and the abusers that might interact with
your system you want to get all the
system components database uh web
application servers um
any kind of
load balancers and
different configuration files it might
be on file systems and so forth you want
to create you want to understand and
identify all the different processes and
data flows that are part of the system
and then any kind of backup or
monitoring or logging components that
are part of the system as well because
again all those things will will come
into play so one thing to keep in mind
about the the scoping though is that you
want to make sure that you're creating
this threat model which is a diagram and
it's basically an architecture diagram
so you want to boil down the workflows
to something uh as small as you can so
you don't want to create you know large
workflows unless of course it's you know
makes sense but the purpose of scoping
small is so that you can
work on a a
given
area
and actually get to the end of the
threat model if you have a large model
with a lot of different
components in it it's going to be
difficult for you to be able to uh
tackle that whole thing
you know like the common phrase of how
you eat an elephant
you do it one bite at a time so you want
to try to scope it as small as possible
so you can concentrate on small areas
get to a finished
threat threat model and then be able to
move on so the diagram must help you
understand and discuss you know the
system security considerations uh the
diagram should contain the items
determined in the scope and if you miss
something it's okay
threat models are living documents so
they're things that
you will be able to go back to and
update change as things as you learn
something new again we're going to use
owasp threat dragon and for this so
here's a mockup of a simple web
application
and you're going to see
a user and an admin and then that dotted
line is a boundary
they go through the web server which
then goes to the app server which then
goes to a database sorry that's a typo
there but it then goes to the database
but the important thing here is to draw
make sure you have boundaries that you
include
all the components of the system now
again this is a very very simple web
application obviously this is just for
demo purposes um a true threat model is
going to be much more robust than this
so now you have the diagram you want to
start looking at what can go wrong and
there's a couple different threat
modeling frameworks and so
one of the most popular ones or i
shouldn't say popular but one of the
more common ones is stride and stride
stands for spoofing tampering
repudiation information disclosure
denial service and elevation of
privileges
and so it classifies threats into those
uh those six categories so spoofing is
somebody being able to impersonate an
account tampering is
uh changing data so that it's not in the
original form it was in
repudiation is being able to tie back an
activity to a given
account or user information disclosure
is confidentiality breach denial service
is an availability breach and then
elevation of privileges is being able to
escalate or elevate a user's
privilege to a higher level in order to
perform additional tasks so let's take a
look at threat drag it's a pretty simple
tool again it's pretty intuitive but
what we're going to do here is uh
get started with a completely new empty
threat model just going to create a new
model
here and i'm gonna go ahead and just
call this
my web app
uh owner is me
reviewer is
jane doe
and system description we're just going
to call this um
[Music]
website for
cat pictures
okay
now i'm going to go ahead and add a new
diagram and just call this the web app
add it
save
all right so you see here that it's
going to create this diagram that you
can then open
and it's a blank canvas it's in stride
right now
meaning that's the way we're going to
categorize these vulnerabilities where
these threats will be fine
so first thing i'm going to do is put
down uh two actors i want to have a
basic user
and i'm going to have an admin uh that's
able to log into the site to make
changes
now put down two processes
going to make this the
web server
make this the app server
and i'm going to put down a store
which is going to be
the database
i'm going to put down a trust boundary
so obviously
the access is going to be over the
internet
okay
so what you want to do is because the
user is going to be accessing the web
server it's pretty simple to do this
here with threat dragon is you're able
to just click on the arrow here it's
going to say select another part of the
model
and there you go and then i'm going to
create another flow that goes between
the web server and the app server
another one that goes back to the
database
same thing here
and
there you go
that's your basic threat model now in
order to manage threats
first thing we can do is let's say we
want to look at the threats on the web
server we can add stride elements to
this and it's going to give you just
basically generic elevation of
privileges and you can see here it says
one of six so it's going to add all of
the stride category threats to this so
i'm not going to step through each one
of them here but
we're going to accept a basic or generic
elevation of privileges
we'll accept the basic spoofing
and so forth
you can click do this for remaining it's
going to add them all and so you'll see
here that elevation of privileges you
know spoofing tampering uh repudiation
information disclosure denial service
and elevation privileges so stride or
have all been added and you can take a
look at this and say yeah there's a
spoofing attack here on the web server
you can add additional description here
if you have it mitigated here we'll say
that we have
mfa
enabled
and
[Music]
strong authentication
and same mitigated save
and it's going to mark it as being
mitigated
now you could also add
your own threats let's say
the web server
um i want to add another threat so i can
say add new threat
let's say the um
admin
credentials i know this is kind of
contradictory to what i just put there
but credentials
are shared
and static
so it never changes it's shared
um in this case that would be a
spoofing um you could because there's no
accountability you could say a spoofing
you could say it's repudiation depending
on uh the case here but
if the credentials are shared and it
gets loose within the organization
you can say it's also possibly elevation
of privileges if it goes to
if a non-admin user is able to gain
access to that so i'm just gonna again
just for demo purposes here i'm just
gonna add this
and we could say here that uh mfa you
know again is is the mitigation um which
again i'm just showing this here as an
example these are all just uh samples
here but mfa enabled
so therefore it's mitigated
okay
and so you would be able to do this with
the remainder of your
the remainder of the threat model here
you can mark things out of scope um just
put in your
reason for being out of scope if you are
going to do that
there is some opportunity here to add
privilege levels and things like that
the store
has additional components that you're
able to
add to reduce reduced threats or show
that some of the threats might be
mitigated and so forth but again this is
just a simple way of doing a quick and
dirty threat model and be able to track
the mitigations that are there and so
with that i hope you enjoyed this little
walk through and
have a good day thank you